at 54 years old Mikhail Gorbachev became
the youngest leader of the Soviet Union
and he was to be the last
few would doubt that he changed the
course of 20th century history although
he's revered and respected more in the
west than in modern Russia
one of his biggest achievements was
signing a disarmament treaty with U.S
president Ronald Reagan that took out a
whole class of nuclear weapons it earned
him a Nobel Peace Prize
Joe Biden cited this achievement in his
tribute describing Gorbachev as a man of
remarkable vision
he said the result was a safer world and
greater freedom for millions of people
Antonio Gutierrez the U.N Secretary
General said the world has lost a
towering Global leader committed
multilateralists and tireless advocate
for peace
the EU commission president Ursula Von
de Lyon said Gorbachev played a crucial
role to end the Cold War and bring down
the Iron Curtain it opened the way for a
free Europe
Gorbachev had a huge impact on the
course of world history he deeply
understood reforms when necessary and
strove to offer Solutions many Russians
see him as the man who stood by as the
Soviet Union disintegrated his legacy is
that he allowed for the peaceful
collapse
of the Soviet Union he did not use
massive Force to keep Eastern Europe
in the Empire and for that he deserves
credit but it is not that this was
someone who came in trying to undermine
the system he tried to reform it
Gorbachev used perestroika all
restructuring to reform a stagnant
economy that had seen people short of
food and consumer goods
and he used glasnost openness and
freedom of speech that led to parts of
the Eastern Bloc rising up against
communism
it was the beginning of the end of the
Cold War one state after the other broke
away Angela Merkel former German
Chancellor spoke in her tribute of the
fear in East Germany with expectation
the tanks would roll in but quite the
contrary wasn't long before the Berlin
Wall came down
yet now 30 years on with Russia's
invasion of Ukraine comes the danger of
further East-West conflict
Russia and its president are digging new
trenches in Europe and have started a
horrible war in Ukraine it's now we
think of Mikhail Gorbachev and realize
what he did for our country and all of
Europe and
Gorbachev held as a man of Peace has
died at a time when his country is
heavily engaged in war
Andrew Simmons Al Jazeera